you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now I just
drove by that Smith's at Sky Canyon this
morning oh you did it's like it's way up
there it's Lisa like the end of the
world but it's huge okay it's kind of up
that way
so this is a great view from our camera
at Sunset Station obviously that's way
down in the southeast part of the valley
you can see this trip here and look what
the snow that Mother Nature has dropped
no new snow has anticipated anytime soon
so officially it's 57 degrees at Reed
International but what's happening in
your neighborhood well all temperatures
all neighborhoods are up a couple of
degrees from 24 hours ago and it feels
even nicer without that wind 54 for
Summerlin 53 out at the Lakes the Air
Force Base you have kicked it up to 60.
not quite 70 Death Valley mid 50s over
the Huntsman prop not down to the low
teens this morning in Ely but all of
those numbers are going to be coming
back later next week and it is not 553
degrees in Searchlight that would be a
problem we are going for 60 today now
that has been the forecast high every
single day this week we have missed it
by that much made it to 59 yesterday but
look at the low this morning almost 10
degrees below normal no threat to the
records which by the way were set not
too long ago so let's check in this next
system is already coming on Shore in the
Pacific Northwest now the winds tomorrow
as we mentioned not going to be quite as
strong as the past couple of days maybe
breezes to 20 or 25 miles an hour and
have you talked to your family and
friends back east in Buffalo New York
they're talking about three feet of snow
the mayor there telling folks to do
their shopping now and stay indoors okay
your most accurate eight day forecast
breezy tomorrow 60 again maybe drop into
the upper 50s over the weekend still
those lows in the upper 30s as we look
ahead towards turkey day now we do have
more wind coming in on Tuesday and a
couple of clouds but a sunny 62 on
Thanksgiving Day Heather feet of snow in
Buffalo yeah